i noticed you have this obsession
obsession on instagram with lost gloves
and anyone who knows you and follows you
understands that there's something going
on with you and lost gloves well it's
lost objects but it started with lost
gloves and i first of all there's a
story behind them all what happened what
happened to its mate how did this look
go glove get lost is some is someone
going to keep the other glove at home on
the off chance or they're going to pair
it up uh it's it's a little bit of you
know romeo and juliet kind of quality to
it there's a you're saying there's a
little bit of a hint of sadness to these
uh it's like it's telling you a tale but
you don't know what the tales they're
all bittersweet city adventures let's
take a look at some of these i want to
put this up this is one you took and uh
yeah now
tell me what's going on here why does
this what is this so evocative to you
well first of all i don't touch them i
just see them and i photograph them so i
have i have no you don't want your dna
on that well you know
well it could be a crime scene let's
let's not give the cops a break it feels
to me like they went down into that door
somehow
well and they were grabbing on and then
they were sucked in and the glove is the
only thing telling you this is me i was
here that that's funny you should say
that because actually that's upside down
it was a glove stuck to the ceiling and
that's a great no i'm joking
[Laughter]
you just blew so many minds here and now
they're like oh that's not fair one of
those escher paintings let's look at the
next one you have so many stories behind
these oh and now look at this uh okay
i'm not bragging but that's my shoe
because i had to get and what is it you
aren't bragging yeah you really aren't
southampton.net and doesn't that almost
look like an obscene gesture yes
close it's like well someone was trying
to make coco with their hands but they
got screwed up somehow i don't think
that's good and now now look at look at
the hands there first it's it's like
it's like a felt glove or a fleece glove
and you see see the detricus of autumn
there yeah the fallen leaves that is
next to it you're a poet you really are
a
is that like that yeah and i'm i'm i'm
wearing i'm wearing uh i think that's a
doc martin shoe that's right next to it
so again i didn't i didn't touch it i
just i just saw it and i said now the
the the the problem now is that people
um now know that i
am interested in in uh
lost glove photos
uh and i think i've i think i've been
set up once you felt like this one i
think was a setup now come on that
doesn't look real no i know and i fell
for this i was in a mexican what a great
mexican restaurant in baton rouge
um and uh i came out we were heading out
afterwards and i said oh my god the
parking oh my god i lost club this is my
thing so i took a picture of it
and i posted it almost instantaneously
and then i said
wait a minute now
first of all it looks like an ad for
chevy
by the way if i could just take a second
the chevy silverado isn't it
[Laughter]
it's really i think pound for bound the
best uh pickup it's the available it's
the jd power number one and it's class
conan
guess who's each get it we're each
getting free chevys now because we work
that in
congratulations thank you very much
so there was also something about i
baton rouge was so warm at that time
there's no reason anybody would have
gloves on their hands so i think someone
saw me eating mexican food chowing down
uh and then ran out found a glove that
they actually kept in the glove
compartment of their car oh uh and threw
it out there at its bait to see if i was
gonna fall for it
and i did and i posted it and before i
got my car and went back i went back
into the restaurant
and said at the at the top of my lungs
let me get this straight
[Laughter]
you all know i'm
here and you think i'm so dumb that i'm
gonna fall for the fake glove spit
and i did and my voice went way up
everybody
everybody laughed
that was that well if we've learned one
thing it's that you have a lot of time
on your hands